a
[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález con la
salida de las tropas internacionales
desplegadas en afganistán eeuu puso fin
a la guerra más larga en la que haya
participado ese país norteamericano 20
años estuvo eeuu y estuvieron allí
también sus aliados de la otan en este
país asiático para hacer una lucha
frontal contra el terrorismo muchas
preguntas por supuesto quedan ahora que
afganistán queda a su suerte y pues bajo
el mandato de el talibán serán
preservados allí los derechos humanos
los derechos de las mujeres quienes van
a reconocer a nivel internacional de
este gobierno formado por el talibán
volver a la represión representan estos
un punto de inflexión en la historia de
eeuu como una potencia mundial tras este
retiro considerado por muchos como
vergonzoso incluso por algunos de los
aliados de eeuu qué pasará entonces con
la otan que también está presentando
serias divisiones al interior de esta
organización y qué pasará con la lucha
antiterrorista es eeuu entonces
es más seguro frente a la amenaza
terrorista dos décadas después de haber
llegado al territorio afgano el panorama
para quienes se quedaron allí no es muy
alentador y la incertidumbre reina en
afganistán veamos
una profunda crisis económica es una de
las múltiples consecuencias de la retoma
del poder por parte de los talibanes en
afganistán
todos los precios han subido y no
podemos comprar nada y la gente tiene
serios problemas económicos porque los
bancos han cerrado y las condiciones del
mercado no son buenas no hay
oportunidades de trabajo y nadie puede
permitirse comprar nada ahora la agencia
de calificación fitch estima que la
economía afgana podría caer casi un 10%
este año fiscal y 5.2 por ciento el
siguiente y en este contexto de bloqueo
económico además agravado por las
sequías los afganos esperan para conocer
lo que será su nuevo gobierno uno del
que un portavoz talibán ya dio adelantos
sin lugar a dudas era un gobierno
islámico la gente ha hecho grandes
sacrificios por el establecimiento de un
gobierno islámico sin embargo se pensara
adecuadamente actualmente estamos
teniendo discusiones y hemos tenido
consultas ojala el liderazgo llegue a
una buena conclusión
se espera que el líder supremo de los
talibanes jaiba to la juntada tenga el
poder final sobre un nuevo consejo de
gobierno y aunque los talibanes prometen
ser más moderados eeuu y la unión
europea desconfían y se enfocan en poder
evacuar a más personas de ese país
y no vamos a reconocer a los talibanes
pero vemos la necesidad de poder tener
un contacto directo de lo contrario no
podemos enviar mensajes y no podemos
escuchar la respuesta uno fue su enfoque
con respecto al aeropuerto durante la
evacuación ahora estamos en un espacio
diferente podremos ver un paso seguro
para salir de afganistán esa sería la
primera prueba bastante importante y
necesitamos poder discutir eso
hasta el gobierno de qatar avanza en
diálogos con los talibanes y trabaja de
la mano de turquía con miras a la
reapertura del aeropuerto de kabul
para analizar este tema hemos invitado a
la doctora jeanne y simon cientista
política es miembro del programa de
estudios europeos y profesora asociada
de ciencias políticas de la universidad
de concepción nos acompaña desde esta
ciudad concepción en chile también está
con nosotros lawrence gum binner él es
abogado analista político está en la
ciudad de washington la capital de
estados unidos y finalmente aquí en el
estudio de france 24 nos acompaña rafael
piñero es analista internacional
profesor de relaciones internacionales
de la universidad externado de colombia
ustedes también nuestros televidentes
son parte de esta conversación a través
de las redes sociales ustedes pueden
dejar los comentarios y también todo
tipo de preguntas las cuentas se las
recuerdo en facebook y en twitter y
también en instagram no se encuentran
como france24
y arroba sant y luego que es mi cuenta
personal deje todos los comentarios con
el numeral el debate efe 24 el también
en varios temas para que ustedes
comenten no solamente del debate que
tenemos en este momento pues comienzo
con nuestra invitada con jim y en la
ciudad de concepción en chile
preguntándole
generales para conocer opiniones frente
a este tema impresiones sobre lo que ha
sucedido en afganistán sobre el futuro
que puede tener este país asiático
bueno como como bien dijo ustedes muy
buenas noches y muchos saludos desde
concepción y bueno después de 20 años de
eeuu de dentro de afganistán con poco
que se puede mostrar de cierta manera
frente una situación que ha seguido de
inseguridad muestro a partir de donald
trump cierto se decide dejar innovar en
sigue el sistema justamente por el apoyo
popular que existe en eeuu para salir de
afganistán y que yo encuentro por un
lado es algo positivo y en eeuu empieza
a dejar de intervenir en la política de
otros países y que va
deslizando que la intervención militar
no es necesariamente la mejor manera de
ir fortaleciendo la democracia y el
estado que es justamente el caso que
pasó en afganistán si miramos lo que
pasó en el s
lawrence para conocer su opinión le hago
la misma pregunta para a partir de a
partir de sus opiniones ya comenzar con
el debate de sus perspectivas sobre lo
que puede pasar en afganistán y lo que
ha sucedido en las últimas semanas en
este país
bueno muy buenas noches gracias santiago
por invitarme yo creo que el pcn de
bairén decidió desde que entró que no
iba a seguir con esta guerra porque
habíamos logrado el objetivo principal
derrotar a al-qaida y matar al
sunderland los otros objetivos de crear
un estado más estable fueron muy
difíciles con mucho esfuerzo y no
estamos logrando y no quería dejar como
estamos en vietnam no salir cuando era
el tiempo ahora la decisión bueno para
muchos estadounidenses la exclusión muy
muy mal hecho y eso ha sido muy
criticado
justifica mente
él
el hecho de que no coordinó con nuestros
aliados
el hecho de que salimos tan rápido sin
preparar la evacuación lo cual
eventualmente lo hizo claro y el hecho
que dejamos mucho a la gente allí ha
quedado en el país sin escape es muy mal
hecho en mi opinión si el estudio de
france24 rafael piñero rafael su opinión
sobre estos hechos recientes y sobre el
futuro que puede tener la planeta la
situación en afganistán será
particularmente difíciles porque creo
que el talibán se enfrenta a dos retos
importantes desde el punto de vista
político mantener la estabilidad y el
orden como lo ha logrado mantener en
algunas regiones en el pasado el
problema de afganistán no se pierde hoy
afganistán y la estabilidad de ese país
se perdió hace más de cuatro años cuando
era inadmisible seguir manteniendo una
situación en la cual el estado y sus
instituciones no lograron desarrollarse
y desde el punto de vista militar creo
que tienen otro desafío y es mantener a
raya la influencia del estado islámico
especialmente el estado islámico
decoraban que se adjudicó el atentado en
afganistán desde la perspectiva de eeuu
creo que internamente las decisiones que
tomaron los últimos tres o cuatro
mandatarios estuvieron encaminadas a
asegurar dos variables que
electoralmente fuera positivo para los
intereses particulares y que
económicamente fuera viable así mismo
hoy 20 años después las perspectivas los
problemas identificados de seguridad
nacional por parte de ese país son
distintos el terrorismo sigue siendo una
variable pero no es la variable más
importante y ahí creo que se produjo una
variable un cambio fundamental que hay
que tener presente yo bailé en lo dijo y
me pegó de lo que dijo mi colega de
debate vamos a hacer una política
exterior para la clase media y eso
quiere decir que hay que validar hay que
refrendar lo que la mayoría piensa y la
mayoría piensa desde hace algún tiempo
que la guerra en afganistán tenía que
terminar haber para comenzar entonces
analizar los diferentes puntos que tengo
para este debate y pensando en el futuro
de lo que puede ser afganistán en unos
cuantos años o en unos pocos meses y
comenzar por el reconocimiento del
talibán a la unión ya he dicho que no lo
va a reconocer muchos organismos
internacionales se han dicho que
simplemente no se van a entender con
ellos pero cuando se cuando culminó el
retiro de las tropas el secretario de
estado de eeuu dijo que estaba dispuesto
a trabajar con el talibán también eeuu
ha dicho que no lo va a reconocer pero
entonces dispuesto a trabajar con quién
y en qué términos y bajo el
entendimiento desde qué punto desde
kabul o de washington hago la ronda la
inversa y comienza entonces con rafael
es muy interesante observar las movidas
diplomáticas que también ha tomado el
talibán recuerde usted que a finales de
julio visitó china y se entrevistó con
el canciller chino wen y al mismo tiempo
a inicios de julio visitó moscú y así
como hace 30 años moscú ve al enemigo
número uno de los talibán 30 años
después puede que las cosas cambien para
los países occidentales será difícil
establecer un diálogo o una negociación
pero si una intermediación ahí vamos a
mirar en qué se traduce eso porque hoy
me parece un poco pronto y prematuro
definir usted puso unos mensajes al
inicio los francos importantes el tema
de los derechos humanos el tema de la
seguridad especialmente en algunas
regiones fronterizas para rusia para
china va a ser indispensable ambos
tienen intereses económicos y ambos
tienen intereses sociales para que se
mantenga cierta estabilidad para francia
para reino unido y para eeuu era mucho
más difícil porque a nivel interno va a
haber una presión muy fuerte
especialmente de la oposición a quienes
hoy están en el gobierno establecer un
diálogo directo y franco con ellos pero
por supuesto tendrá que seguir habiendo
un diálogo entre los distintos actores
especialmente entre los miembros
permanentes del consejo de seguridad los
grandes pero desde la perspectiva de
eeuu no le parece a usted que decir que
van a trabajar con el talibán si éste
respeta lo pactado en todo eso no es
darle un reconocimiento a este grupo
yo creo que sí yo creo que el gobierno
de iovine tenemos que tratar con el
talibán
de una forma u otro no vamos a reconocer
al principio vamos a ver que si cumplen
con los promedios que hicieron en doha y
que hicieron en los meses recientes
cuando empezaron a tomar poder ahora en
la evacuación
cumplieron con sus promesas ese es un
punto a su favor de todos modos muchos
de los promesas de derechos humanos de
la participación de mujeres de un
gobierno más abierto
todavía tenemos que esperar a ver
tenemos que dejar el puerto abierto para
la diplomacia norteamericano no podemos
cerrarlo pero tenemos jojoba tiene que
ser muy duro y muy el mundo va a estar
mirando cómo reacciona jobvite yo creo
que no va a haber un talibán 2.0 no va a
haber un cambio completo desde hace 20
años al mismo tiempo no va a ser
exactamente el mismo talibán por las
personas que mis colegas ya han amputado
gini y su opinión al respecto sobre esta
esta postura de eeuu se acaba la misión
militar y comienza una misión
diplomática como entender eso desde la
perspectiva de eeuu cuando siempre su
proceder ha sido bélico y ha sido como
lo que vimos en afganistán llegará al
territorio llevar tropas ocupar estar
allí y llevar ese modelo de democracia
que ahora cuando terminaron la incursión
en afganistán dijeron que yo nunca había
querido llevar la democracia a
afganistán que simplemente había querido
estar allí para proteger el mundo del
terrorismo
bueno
sigue ese día pero yo diría que hay que
pensar que para estados unidos lo más
importante es la seguridad nacional pero
también
intereses económicos que están dentro
del medio oriente ahora yo estoy de
acuerdo tanto con rafael con condolencia
en cómo se va a ir abordando eeuu el
tema yo creo que van a ser bastante
pragmático buscando equilibrar cierto la
dinámica política doméstica o nacional
en eeuu con
seguridad nacional la ciudad fuera pero
como dije intereses también y me parece
que eeuu desde hace tiempo está cada vez
más débil y como consecuencia yo creo
que va a depender mucho de qatar
especialmente como un aliado que con
quién va a trabajar hay que pensar que
los aviones que se han salido desde
afganistán se pueden acatar justamente
para ir fortaleciendo de cierta manera o
facilitando ese proceso de traslado así
yo creo que va a fortalecer
ojalá justamente
diplomacia más desde medio oriente y nos
debe solamente eeuu jim en con esta
explicación que usted nos hace me surge
una pregunta y es precisamente el papel
que tiene catar que es un país en que
uno pensaría es muy pequeño dentro del
mundo musulmán tiene cierta fuerza
económica por ser pues obviamente un
productor de petróleo y un país con
muchísimo poder en la región del golfo
pero qué interés puede tener catar ser
precisamente ese trampolín de washington
hacia kabul vía doha
yo diría que tiene muchos de cierta
manera y permite fortalecerse dentro de
la región y hay que pensarse a toda la
relación que ahora tiene con
justamente con israel de cierta manera
yo creo que vamos a ver cuando qué está
pasando y en medio oriente un
intercambio de las relaciones hay que
pensar también quién es raya el cierto
a cambio del primer ministro y está más
abierto yo diría confío que en el siglo
21 vamos a ver cosas interesantes
adentro de eventos del medio oriente y
quizás pensar justamente de temas de
vietnam vietnam en ese momento cierto
era muy parecido a afganistán y vietnam
en el actual es un país bastante
desarrollado uno de los mejores países
en asia en relación al manejo de kobe 19
como esto de cierta manera podemos
imaginar también un medio oriente más
estable sin la presencia militar de eeuu
lawrence y que podemos decir de otros
países que estaban haciendo presencia en
afganistán como puede ser la relación
con este nuevo
gobierno que se va a instalar allí habló
de países como el reino unido que además
tiene una larga historia de presencia
en el siglo pasado y en el siglo 18
donde actualmente es afganistán y otros
países como alemania como francia que
incluso desde alemania hicieron muchas
críticas a la forma como eeuu manejó
esta situación
si efectivamente están tiago yo creo que
uno de los daños más grandes de ese
episodio para estados unidos ha sido el
daño en la relación con nuestros aliados
y no es sólo que salimos es la manera en
que decimos la falta de correlación la
consulta y ellos con razón están tienen
mucho malestar con nuestros audios y con
giovanni en este momento ahora ellos
como nosotros la primera responsabilidad
es urgente y yo creo que si hay gente
que fueron dejados de parte de los
americanos o europeos o de otros países
que merecen ser secuestrados o sujetos
a terror de parte de talibán puede caer
muy mal sobre esos gobiernos y sobre los
estados unidos y el otro país que es un
gran perdedor en todo eso es la india
porque esto fortalece a pakistán
fortalece a la china los gran enemigo de
la envía y envía up ha puesto ha
apostado mucho con los eeuu en esta
situación y ellos fueron dejado también
por sorpresa y no en una buena situación
actualmente rafael aquí en el estudio de
france 24 impresiones de cómo pueden ser
la relación de los países europeos que
están molestos con eeuu y le pregunto si
hay ciertas fragmentaciones o algunas
grietas al interior de la otan después
del manejo que se le ha dado esta
situación y le hago una tercera pregunta
ahí que piensan ahora en europa de eeuu
porque cuando llegó by den al poder
europa lo vio con con de una manera
positiva incluso la canciller angela
merkel dijo eeuu ya regresó vuelve a ser
nuestro aliado internacional pensarán lo
mismo en este momento bueno si miramos
los últimos 20 años afganistán se
convirtió en un catalizador
continuos y constantes
grietas o fisuras como ustedes lo
mencionó entre los eeuu y sus aliados
europeos alrededor de la inversión que
individualmente hacían a la otan
recuerde usted que ha sido un reclamo
básicamente desde la administración de
george bush y en el último documento
estratégico de la otan del 2010 el
terrorismo sigue siendo una prioridad
pero desde ese momento hasta hoy no se
han puesto de acuerdo en una
actualización hoy sigue habiendo
profundas disputas y a pesar de que joe
biden hace poco más de dos meses cuando
estuvo en europa trató de calmar y de
decirle a sus aliados europeos aquí
estoy de vuelta voy a consultar con
ustedes la primera reacción es no
necesariamente fue así porque nuestra
primera intención como lo decía mi
colega fue retirar a los nuestros y al
escuchar esa voz sin duda alguna tuvo
que acelerar ese plan que estaba
planeado para el 11 de septiembre y lo
tuvo que adelantar porque la situación
se hizo insostenible ahí hubo profundas
profundas grietas pero quisiera volver
el problema también es nacional al
interior de los para a la crítica sobre
johnson hacia manuel mccomb hacia angela
merkel que está de salida a finales de
este mes sin duda alguna va a ser un
momento complejo y afganistán fue la
causa de muchas de las dificultades
euroatlánticas en los últimos 20 años
como queda entonces la otan después de
esto en el último consejo estratégico en
el último concepto estratégico del 2010
se evitó que se volviera a producir una
situación en la cual la otan actuará por
fuera de su rango y es él el atlántico
norte es decir la otan se creó como una
organización de seguridad y defensa
colectiva principalmente para evitar un
ataque de la unión soviética o de alguno
de sus aliados se le dio vida a través
de distintas actualizaciones que se
llevaron a cabo en la década del 90 y
del 2000 hice una ampliación
significativa a partir a partir de la
presión política y diplomática que la
administración de george bush hizo sobre
sus aliados europeos porque nunca
estuvieron de acuerdo recuerde usted que
en distintos momentos los presidentes
franceses y alemania hicieron un bloque
alrededor de no es nuestro problema no
es problema de la otan porque el auto no
tiene otros objetivos y a partir de allí
hubo diferencias que generaron que la
isaf se estableciera en el año de 2004
cuando terminaron las operaciones
militares y tuvieron un largo recorrido
de hecho una de las dificultades para
que la otan siguiera ejerciendo la
misión de acompañamiento a las tropas de
seguridad fue la pandemia la pandemia
tuvo un efecto perverso sobre la
estabilidad misma de afganistán porque
no tuvo como y al mismo tiempo sobre las
tropas estadounidenses que aún se
encontraban allí aproximadamente cinco
mil hombres y de las tropas de la
alianza del atlántico norte que ejercía
acompañamiento sobre las tropas de
seguridad afganas
jim y en la ciudad de concepción allí en
el sur de chile
pensando a futuro en afganistán el tema
que más le preocupa tal vez a la
comunidad internacional es el tema de
los derechos humanos y el de los
derechos y el papel que va a tener la
mujer en esta sociedad gana que no
tenemos todavía indicios de cómo puede
llegar a hacer tenemos unos antecedentes
de cómo fue esa es el primer gobierno
del talibán en los 90 pero no sabemos
cómo va a ser este nuevo talibán que
salen sus voceros hablando en cnn dando
conferencias de prensa declaraciones y
mostrándose muy abiertos a tener canales
diplomáticos con occidente como ve usted
el tema de los derechos allí se puede
confiar en este nuevo talibán 2.0
mediático digámoslo así
ojalá pero no yo no no creo
además una de las preocupaciones a nivel
internacional es justamente que china y
rúsia va a quedar en ninguno de esos dos
gobiernos
actúan muy activamente para proteger a
los derechos humanos en general los
derechos de las mujeres en particular y
ese donde justamente yo diría la unión
europea tiene como mayor presencia de
defensa de derechos humanos de manera no
militar en distintos países es cierto
por ejemplo aquí en américa latina bueno
uno de espera que va a haber presencia
pero una presencia más bien civil de
distintos organizaciones que van a ir
trabajando justamente con
lideresas que hay principalmente en
kabul porque hay que reconocer lo que
pasa en común que hay mucho más una
ciudad grande mucho más urbana mucho más
moderna sí quiere decir mucho más
occidental pero cuando uno va saliendo
de la ciudad a los distintos territorios
donde no hubo mucho llegado a la
democracia y en general las mujeres
quedan adentro de sus casas y viven una
vida bastante conservadora muestro por
eso me parece que para muchos
territorios no va a ser y va a ser de
matica más para nosotros quizás que para
ellas pero si uno piensa en la selección
femenina de fútbol
los ingenieras jóvenes que han trabajado
tema de robótica la periodistas etcétera
como sobre hay una preocupación
internacional en relación al tema claro
y es que una cosa es kabul un universo
aparte es kabul y un universo son las
provincias y tiene una geografía tan
accidentada este país que regiones que
no hablan ni siquiera el mismo idioma no
comparten la misma cultura son tribus o
etnias completamente diferentes
hay regiones donde prácticamente allí no
no ha pasado en miel tal evans y eeuu y
siguen viviendo como hace un siglo atrás
lawrence en la ciudad de washington
quería preguntarle ahora y tal parece
que el talibán aprendió una lección
durante estos 20 años se replegó
aprendió lo vemos como lo decía ahora
mucho más mediático hablando con prensa
occidental hablando tanto entrevistas en
inglés y tal parece que el mundo
occidental que los aliados
internacionales no aprendieron la
lección en estos 20 años como lo ve
usted
bueno esa es una perspectiva interesante
yo creo que es el talibán está haciendo
muy práctico en su discurso
internacional o sea ellos saben que si
llegan con un discurso que dice que
vamos a regresar como hermosa de 20 años
sería un desastre es algo muy práctico
económicamente
defienden en la asistencia internacional
y saben que para arrancar con la
economía tienen que por lo menos sentar
con el mundo occidental
y tienen que empezar a negociar algunos
costos
no tiene no hay fe que ellos van a
cambiar completamente
con razón pero yo creo que ellos saben
algo nosotros yo nos diría que no hemos
aprendido nada en 20 años yo creo que ha
habido los logros que hemos hablado del
avance de la mujer y derechos humanos en
afganistán que si no van a seguir en
directo proyectos logros y van a quedar
y yo le digo que no hemos aprendido las
lecciones porque la escena el
helicóptero partiendo del aeropuerto de
kabul o de algún sector de kabul es
prácticamente una repetición de una
imagen que vimos en vietnam hace unas
décadas atrás por eso por eso le digo y
le planteó que puede ser que no
aprendimos totalmente la lección
florence sigo con usted para hacerle una
pregunta que concierne a su país a eeuu
es eeuu después de estos 20 años de
incursión militar en afganistán y de
haber estado allí para hacerle frente al
terrorismo es un país más seguro en este
momento frente a la lucha del terrorismo
o como cree usted que está la situación
y yo yo creo que estamos en un parque
más seguro un parte menos seguro o sea
este ritmo los yihadistas han crecido en
los últimos 20 años
y han expandido su territorio afuera de
afganistán afuera de medio oriente está
básicamente en todo el mundo y eso fue
un argumento de iovine diciendo que no
podemos tener tropas no podemos tener
presencia en cada país donde hay riesgo
del terrorismo tenemos que tener otra
manera de prevenir los ataques
terroristas
en un nivel global entonces lo que sí ha
pasado que no hemos tenido una
repetición del 11 de septiembre en 20
años en ese aspecto hemos logrado mucho
pero el riesgo es tan grande como
siempre y no sabemos qué pueda pasar de
aquí en adelante ahora que otros grupos
extremistas se han sentido un poco
apalancados con esta llegada del talibán
otra vez al poder me quedan pocos
minutos ya el programa rafael para la
conclusión tres puntos importantes la
democracia aquí a nivel internacional
como queda como queda yo byd en el
presidente de eeuu y como queda el papel
de eeuu como fuerza mundial del orden a
nivel internacional después de esto
bueno el papel de la democracia creo que
como lo dicen mis colegas va a tener un
trabajo principalmente a partir de redes
de la sociedad civil usa y médicos sin
fronteras otro tipo de instituciones que
pueden tener un acceso mucho más fácil a
lo que va a significar el futuro próximo
de afganistán es necesario y ahí creo
que se van a consigue a concentrar
muchos de los esfuerzos porque el brazo
militar no funcionó pero la diplomacia
los principios y valores la necesidad de
fortalecer el papel de la mujer de las
minorías étnicas sexuales y religiosas
es mostrar que hay cultura deporte y
otros elementos puede ser un catalizador
y un dinamizador
y un fortalecimiento en el mediano en el
largo plazo en el corto es muy difícil
es muy difícil lograrlo porque sin duda
alguna sabe que hay que lograr santiago
gobernanza estado de derecho y ahí es
donde se perdió la batalla en los
últimos 20 años momentáneamente no
sabemos qué nos depara el futuro el
segundo elemento como queda el papel de
los eeuu comparte lo que decía lawrence
en el sentido de si miramos las
estrategias de seguridad nacional del
2017 y del 2021 que es transitoria es
que son escasos párrafos o líneas las
que se le dedica el tema de afganistán
porque hoy la prioridad pasa por los
problemas de ciberterrorismo en la
disrupción que puede haber en el
suministro de petróleo gas o de otros
elementos y principalmente la
competencia con china y rúsia en otros
escenarios estratégicos entonces hoy es
muy improbable que haya un ataque como
lo hubo el 11 de septiembre del 2001 que
estamos a pocos días de su aniversario
de la conmemoración pero sin duda alguna
pero sin duda alguna hay otros desafíos
que se han venido creando hoy la
preocupación es seguirnos recuperando de
una panda la cual no hemos terminado de
salir y todavía no hemos visto al
talibán gobernando una cosa es estar en
terreno y no lo hemos visto gobernando
en su conclusión rápidamente un minuto y
afganistán hacia el futuro como vio este
panorama en líneas generales ya
en líneas generales va a ser muy
complicado ha sido un como dice el
gremio de los imperios por ciclos
entonces es en el fondo es una sociedad
tribal va a ser seguir siendo tribal y
yo creo que la yihad y tati van a
aprovechar este gobierno para seguir
haciendo sus coordinaciones pero el
resto del del mundo del mundo occidental
es aprender a controlar pero no tratar
de inventar y crear una democracia
occidental en la canasta eso no va a
funcionar tenemos que proteger nuestros
intereses y prevenir el terrorismo
fuente de
además que nadie ha preguntado a los
afganos si ellos quieren el modelo de
democracia occidental o si ellos quieren
tener un modelo de democracia organizado
dentro de sus parámetros y dentro de su
concepción como un país de diferentes
tribus como lo que explicamos ahora
donde hay tayikos uzbekos donde hay
tantas etnias mezcladas dejo para el
cierre
jim y en la ciudad de concepción en
chile sus impresiones su perspectiva de
lo que puede seguir de aquí en adelante
y retoma algo que decía rafael el papel
de china que va a tener allí en
afganistán ya tienen embajada o van a
abrir una embajada y en kabul
sí bueno yo imagino que ustedes saben
que chile es uno de los exportadores de
cobre principal en el mundo pero el
cobre también adentro de afganistán
también hay litio de dentro de
afganistán nuestro chino está allá y ha
generado buenos caminos etcétera
justamente para aprovechar ese recurso
natural que existen dentro del país
muestra china idioma chino para
fortalecer su presencia ya y quizás ese
misma presencia porque conviene de china
también que a estabilidad para que pueda
seguir aprovechando ese recurso natural
que logra generando cierto estabilidad
pero sin transformar mucho la sociedad
yo imagino que ese sería ideal porque yo
he escuchado es justamente que los
talibanes están unidos actualmente
frente a la oposición a eeuu pero uno de
ellos que se va hasta los señores ahora
queda que pueden ir peleando en ese
vacío de poder como china que izapa va a
ayudar para generar estabilidad
pues a mis tres invitados de hoy les
agradezco por haber compartido con
nosotros los puntos de vista jim y simon
lawrence caminería rafael piñero aquí en
el estudio de france 24 gracias por
habernos acompañado y a ustedes también
gracias por la sintonía pueden seguir
con la programación de france 24 siga
con nosotros
[Música]